working on it there we go okay get that
and I was gonna oh ha ha there we go
so hang on a second I got a I got a
wrench to give out over here
there we go guessing the title is in
relation to your Joker review um and
sort of um basically like I've I've been
in a bit of an adversarial mood and part
of that's the Joker review I suspect but
I mean on Saturday I was part of um of a
burlesque show that was completely based
around inclusivity and representation
and you know a lot of very powerful and
emotionally draining numbers so you know
that kind of got me had a bit of a
fighting mood too so I have no idea this
is gonna turn out I may regret setting
this up
ah lovely scarf yes I wish I could claim
this this I got off at sea this is my
gender-fluid scarf which I'm quite fond
of just wanted to say hi but I but I'm
seeing Joker in an hour well I hope you
get more out of it than I did well from
the Balkans oh that's a first
what's that in your water oh I'm having
hot cider today no additions
it's fall it's it's warmed up cider
season there's a cinnamon stick in there
because that's how you do it properly Oh
nobody dies from this debate I don't
know man mood I've been in lately I'm
not sure I want to make any promises how
are things you know what they're not bad
overall um things are okay I'm just like
I said mom I'm in a bit of a those are
fighting words mood
so we'll see what results on that debate
me did your job or if you get people
angry as some of them not a ton I don't
think I checked off that many people I
think at this point my reputation is
pretty well established so I think by
now most people know what mm-hmm
have a sense of what they're gonna get
oh when they come in Daleks and
Manhattan two-parter is really stupid
but it's really stupid fun I enjoy the
gossiping Daleks and tenant's
performance is stellar I wish that I
could find the fun in the stupid I have
a hard time with that one I'm really
sorry stupid fun is a valid thing I
I like GI Joe Rise of Cobra cause it's
stupid fun so like I'm not immune to
that just sayin
is it is it pumpkin spice no no pumpkin
spice - cider no no do that to your
coffee if you're gonna do it to anything
forgot about this in the middle oh hang
on
app lost it forgot about this in the
middle of Dark Crystal when I remembered
hot cider is great by the way
Fame season oh yeah Outsiders wonderful
I saw eggnog last month it is too early
for eggnog like Jim mm-hmm
no no no no no no like cider fine it's
perfect season if you're into pumpkin
spice have that it's not Agnon season
yet we got to get into November before
you can start pulling eggnog on me once
we're there go nuts
I love eggnog
that's all pumpkin spice dog treats to
go figure I'm pretty sure I saw those a
while ago even when I disagree with you
40% of the time I can very rarely say I
think you're wrong I I'm always happy
with that response hi what do you think
of brexit oh boy
okay I think I can safely say that
regardless of whether you think it was a
good idea or not the executional
implementation of the thing holy crap I
get you I think it became very clear
very quickly that the people who wanted
it didn't really know how to get it
besides just saying give us frankly give
us frankly give us break set so I just
I'm in a place where even if you think
breaks it is a good idea I don't know
how anyone could look at what's going on
and go this was a great way that we
handled this process it's too early for
Christmas in general yes it is it's
Halloween season it's it's creepy season
yeah definitely totally for Christmas
I don't even celebrate it because I'm
Jewish I can only imagine that that
makes it rougher
the gang or two partners severely
underrated a whole bunch of fun not
really sure if you'll agree with or
disagree to be honest I will agree with
you what is it it's a rebel rebel flesh
and the almost people that's a really
epital rated two-parter I'm really
looking forward to getting to it
because I've already washed in a while
but it's good it's really good I got a
backup hell-bent is this good is good as
a standalone episode fight me it would
have to stand alone is not even being
Doctor Who if you're gonna make it that
degree of standalone sure it's fine
within the context of Doctor Who is a
show not even specifically in the
context of coming off the back of Heaven
Sent
and face the Raven no it's not if that
thing is ever gonna work at all it needs
to work completely in isolation away
from anything Doctor Who cuz no no and
yes clearly I will fight you uh-uh
I thought Amy's choice was we it was
weak the first time should i rewatch i
mean i would say especially if you enjoy
Amy and Rory's dynamic I yeah give it
another shot if you don't and you don't
know you're not a particular fan of
those characters then no you're probably
not gonna get anything more out of it on
it's like a viewing I've always liked
that episode and I appreciated it even
more on the really watch which doctor do
you think Donna would be best with other
than ten twelve I I would love to see
the two of them butt heads so did Briggs
that actually happened um not yet did it
wasn't Briggs it a few years ago I'm in
America I don't read up so the brexit
vote the vote for the for Britain to
leave the EU the British exit IV brexit
that happened that happened about three
years ago were they voted that that was
what they were going
to do it hasn't happened yet because
they can't come to an agreement with the
EU as to how it's going to happen or
more specifically the British government
cannot come with an agreement in and of
itself as to whether or not they will
agree to the terms that the EU has set
out and if they can't come to terms with
the EU they just crash out and it
becomes a massive mess there have been
years of negotiations trying to avoid
that scenario and they push back their
deadline a few times trying to get it
worked out but there's not a lot to
indicate that it's gonna get sorted by
the latest deadline which is is it this
month or next month it's coming up it's
soon again conjecture doctor who would
benefit from becoming a generic show
that is multiple independent teams
working on stories simultaneously like
each Network having their version huh
that's an interesting proposal my fear
is that there is a fairly distinct
overall flavor to Doctor Who and that's
actually a big part of why I stand by
you know however you want to cast the
doctor the doctor should be British from
somewhere in those islands because I
think that's a big part of the
specifically British flavour of the show
so if you want to do something like that
the one thing I would say is don't like
just send off a unit to work out of
America I for one don't want an American
Doctor Who but if they were to I don't
know theoretically run in parallel you
know with different show runners and a
different overall approach to the
storytelling you know two doctors at the
same time you know eleventh over on this
channel and it's more of a swashbuckling
adventure 12 on this channel it's more
of a it's more of an extended character
piece ten over on this channel where
it's more of a character drama you know
maybe I would worry about
overload with a scenario like that
though please don't talk about brings it
I didn't bring it up don't don't don't
come at me for that uh where was I let's
see Donna and seven would be great okay
yeah I I could go for that thank you
very much Amanda I greatly appreciate it
let's see I found Russell T Davies
approach to story arcs and continuity
far more engaging I the thing is I can
make an argument I I agree but I don't
want it to sound like I don't like my
office approach there were things Moffat
did that I really did appreciate and as
much as he failed to completely shake
off the mystery box overarching story he
did it less egregiously than Davies dead
at least as far as the stuff that bugs
me so I appreciate that but what I will
tell you is I've been getting Liz into
Doctor Who gradually and on a selective
viewing basis I'm not having her watch
the whole thing I'm picking the episode
she's gonna watch once we hit him off
it's gonna get a lot tougher because
because of the way he did overall season
stories which broadly speaking I prefer
it does mean that there are episodes
that are plot essential in order to get
what's going on for the season that
otherwise as far as the self containing
the story that is going on in them I
would skip so like quality episode I'd
skip it but its plot essentials so I
need to decide do I have her watch that
do I do we skip it and I fill her in on
the necessary details that's sort of the
risk you run when you stretch the story
out more integrated into the narrative
is that it gets you sometimes get the
story tied to weaker episodes doing that
Boris Johnson can oh okay well Ella you
got some feelings so do you as an
American keep up on world politics is it
an inch
for you um do I keep up no I certainly
don't claim to I have a general sense of
like some stuff I catch bits and pieces
I'll listen to the radio driving to work
and I listened and I listen I listen to
NPR which is National Public Radio and
they do actually broadcast BBC news hour
at some point so you know I get bits of
pieces of what's going on elsewhere but
I don't go out of my way - I don't go
out of Micra way to follow American news
either I actually really don't like the
news the news tends to depress me but
you know to some degree I like it
there's only so much I could stick my
head in the sand and pretend this stuff
isn't going on so you know pig slaves
wonder blue wonderfully absurd let's be
clear folks is talking about the the
doll exam in hand two-parter he pays
anyone is missing contacts pineapple and
pizza is an abomination to bay me I will
not debate you because you are simply
wrong there is no debate to be had good
day so coming back pink slaves are
wonderfully absurd if you can look past
the accents then the acting is good hmm
that's a big thing to ask me to look
past Dalek SEC is really interesting in
his death his impactfully yes but he
looks awful it's terrible but this
little freaking they look like sex toy
guys on the side of his head but yeah
dude I'm sorry maybe you don't see that
cuz I'm older than you and I'm a creepy
old pervert but whatever that Alex
haven't truly been great since the
Russell era um I'd actually agree on
that because Moffat kind chickened out
on the Daleks after nobody woman for the
new paradigm and we've gotten a fair
number of Davros stories I would argue
we haven't had a Dalek story since I
guess into the Dalek well until
resolution actually did like resolution
but like we haven't had a good doll X as
a group store in a long time because the
last few we've had into the doll like
resolution they have focused on a single
Dalek and that's not a bad thing that
works but I feel like they've been doing
that because they've lost the thread on
them as an as a group as a mass bring it
back down victory of the Daleks is a
good story victory of the Daleks is
almost a good story so sorry nah it's
not bad like I'm not gonna argue too
much on that because I defend it more
than a lot of people I know I still
think it's got a lot of issues though
pineapple pumpkin spice pizza flavored
coffee I try it yesterday here's
something hilarious someone compared
Benioff one of the game of thrones
showrunners to Cersei both are bad and
planning and think that they are smarter
than they are
oh dear sex toys of the Daleks oh boy
and there goes the monetization how
would you respond to someone who says
LGBT people acting on their feelings as
akin to child predators acting on their
feelings Wow
Wow okay and they say that both are
backed by science okay both are backed
by science insofar as there are links as
far as how sexuality straight and
honestly so is the treatment of
heterosexuals so like we're talking
sexuality in general and don't remove
heterosexuality from that equation
because heterosexuality behaves the same
freakin way so don't separate it out as
if it's somehow different from
everything else so first of all you're
the way the question is worded I have a
really big problem with because it
implies that LGBT Q+ people or actually
more specifically the sexuality stripes
of this because we're not talking the
gender end of it
that sexual minorities you're linking
them to pedophilia because the behavior
of the sexuality insofar as the desire
that someone has behaves in a similar
way which yes that's true but that's
also true of heterosexuality first of
all but the big massive thing is
children can't give consent if you're a
man and you want to be with a man and
you're both adults fine you're a woman
you want to be with a woman you're both
adults
your main you want to be with a man or a
woman at the same time you want to be
with the transfers you want to be with
an asexual you yourself are asexual you
want to be with non-binary as long as
everyone is an adult fine the comparison
to pedophilia breaks down immediately
when you are talking about the way in
which people exhibiting their desires
you cannot compare them because one
brings harm to another person by its
nature brings harm to the other party
involved and that is not to say that
every single homosexual or heterosexual
or bisexual or whatever representation
is solid and wonderful and great harm
can happen there but as long as it's to
adults it's not harming by its nature
mm-hmm now I don't want you to think I'm
mad at you because the way you worded
the question did seem to imply you were
more proposing something that someone
else might ask and I'm not taking it as
granted that you yourself are asking
that question so I'm not mad at you I am
frustrated by the question though so
haha there we go
ah boy let's see
yeah after all that I gotta I gotta find
where I was again I started series 1
even though there's always been stuff
going on I think aliens of London World
War 3 holds up better is more relevant
now than when it came out I mean
honestly it's political satire fear
feels a lot less cartoonish than it used
to
I'll give you that that hasn't that a
depressing thought ah by the way dark is
an amazing show you should try it I've
heard it but I can never remember what
it is like the title super generic you
gotta grant me that to be fair when I
first watch dogs in Manhattan I was too
young to even know what sex was and once
I got older I was already interested in
enough that I didn't care but fair
pineapple on pizza yay or nay I vote yay
I like pineapple on pizza appropriately
handle like you don't just stick whole
slices of pineapple you chunk it and
it's balanced out
it's here's the thing people like
pineapple on pizzas gross like you don't
just slap pineapple on PC you put
pineapple on pizza with ham with bacon
with the flavors that balance it out you
don't just throw pine there's an art to
this it's like any given spice you don't
just throw it onto anything
would you care for some tea uh Peter
Davison is a solid doctor hides in
bushes um that's like here's the thing I
don't like be at this point Peter
Davison is my least favorite doctor if I
am allowed to take Big Finish into
account but it's not that I think he's
bad I just don't get him whatever it is
other people see in his doctor I'm just
not seeing I don't see anything bad I
just don't see what's good about him so
you know I've just filed him under I
don't get it as a paid so I don't
actually get worked up about Davison hmm
mm-hmm how we're really getting
demonetised and I'm here for it oh good
thanks Carolyn I tried to watch series
11 all the way back in April I still
need to finish the last couple of
episodes I hadn't mean series 11 is
really uneven I mean that's that's the
simple truth of it
consent is everything oh good
nice nice agreement on that um it's
always really bugged me when classic
Daleks SEC and the supreme Dalek showed
up in the witch's familiar without any
context or explanation as to why or how
they were there I don't remember seeing
second the which is familiar and the
supreme does supreme Daleks just rank so
it's not I've always presumed that we're
not always seeing the same one you
mentioned that you hate vide this is all
part of my plan villain trophy yep does
it did above you when Missy did it to
Clara in death in heaven or was it
handled better there I honestly I need
to rewatch it because to my memory it
there wasn't a ton that she was directly
manipulating and that a lot of it was
just her rolling with what was going on
that's my memory though I have a
rewatched death in heaven a long time so
I need to watch that one again too with
an eye on that question cuz off top my
head I don't remember how much of the
plan that she is executing required
highly detailed and specific execution
over over an unbelievably long period of
time and also that said like it goes
down slightly better with a Time Lord
than others although I still don't like
it as a trope I didn't know how to
appraise my question better my mom who
was the someone I was referring to is a
very traditional conservative Christian
ah that's there are certain stripes of
society who are very fond of directly
comparing anything that isn't cisgender
and heterosexual to the most extreme
things possible where there is a
theoretical tiny sliver of a logical
connection so they will connect sexual
my sexual preference
minorities - or sexual orientation
minorities not a preference preferences
are choices I like I still stumble over
the terms sometimes they will link
sexual orientation minorities to
pedophilia or they will link
homosexuality to bestiality and it's all
an attempt to link in people's minds how
to adult humans live with each other -
something abominable and they do that
because the argument of two men being in
love or two women being in love or
non-binary people having relationships
or people being transgender or whatever
there isn't actually a lot of
substantive argument to be made against
those actual things so it's simply a
rhetorical argument device to tie it to
something so much worse and to point to
it and go but see how it's like this
thing that everyone agrees is terrible
but much like any slippery slope
argument it's a coward's argument
because you're no longer making an
argument against the thing you're making
argument against this other thing so
with slippery slope arguments it's very
similar you don't argue against the
thing that's going on now you argue
against the theoretical thing that
happens much later as a result of what's
going on now and that's not to say
slippery slope never works but for
slippery slope to be a valid argument
you have to be able to back it up ie you
have to be able to point to real-world
examples where previously X led to Y led
to Z but if you can't cite precedent
then saying we can't allow this because
it might lead to that and that's awful
no because then you're arguing about
something that doesn't even exist as
opposed to the thing that is actually at
the heart of the debate you know like
people's lives
I'm not partial to seeing human beings
reduced to pawns on a chessboard and I
feel like that happens a lot in these
debates on all sides to be clear but a
big part of how the the debates happen
in the first place is by not treating
people as people should be treating them
as a nebulous group treating them as the
other or as a sickness let me back up
blink is overrated I don't for some
people's taste it is I still really like
it do you like chicken pot pie I need to
be in the mood but yes I actually do in
2008 an Israeli animator animator board
document called waltz with bashir was
released it's one of my favorite
animated films ever you owe it to
yourself to watch it I have been meaning
to watch that for a while I still
haven't seen it I've seen the film he
made after I've seen the Congress which
was fascinating but really weird really
really weird that movie and like very
segmented
and oddly enough I liked the non animate
half better than the animated half with
that one Monty Python's Flying Service
turn and Brian's surface circus turned
50 recently oh man oh we're all getting
old good lord
[Music]
see sorry I'm trying to keep up I'm well
behind now cuz haha I've gotten gotten
it off to some rants clearly it takes
you away as jumbled BS ooh
those are fightin words
um I get why it takes you ways into
everybody's liking but
for me it takes you away bears a certain
resemblance to things like a wrinkle in
time and some elements of Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy
the heavier age of sci-fi when it wasn't
always about rocket ships but about the
expansion of the mind and I miss that
era of sci-fi a bit to a certain degree
that's even going on in 2001 a Space
Odyssey much as I don't actually like
that movie and I felt like that was
invoking the more mindscape style
science fiction that like I missed and I
got it so much with it takes you away
but if that's not your jam I get why
people don't like it but like I love it
I love that episode to death what would
you like to see a spider burst style
Batman Joker comic or a man or animated
film where every main live-action and
animated Batman and Joker Duke it out um
I mean that's the kind of thing I feel
like I'd like to see as a 20-minute
short I'm not sure I care for a feature
length out of that be fun for a lark how
would you describe the song American Pie
um oh god I don't even know like I'm not
a good person to ask to describe music
anyway cuz I don't know the vocabulary
to describe properly to strike and
describe it properly I'll have another
drink this is going well um but I mean I
think that song and I just think about
cast parties in high school where the
the director you know we bust out the
guitar and that would be one of the
things he would sing and not everyone
would sing the verse but everyone will
come in at the chorus every time it's
it's very much that kind of group you
know you just feel like you know the
lighters kind of it's it's a unifying
kind of song it makes you it just kind
of makes you warm I've seen towns of
wangcheng
what did you think I haven't seen that
one yet I'll hopefully get to that on
the classic who review now that I've
actually got that up and running uh have
you heard of the radio series nebulous
nope
I've been heard of most radio series I
don't listen to a lot of radio shows
it's a parody of classic sci-fi
including Doctor Who starring Mark
Gatiss I've been curious to check it out
I've liked a lot of bark Davis's work
that hasn't been on Doctor Who or at
least not writing I actually think he's
been good as an actor but he's writing
on doctor who has not done a lot for me
but I'm like a lot of what I've seen
from him elsewhere so it's funny I like
to be fair uh adventure in time and
space
he wrote that and that was great so of
the dangling plot threads his face of
BOE kind of left in a weird state and
never felt resolved people get hung up
on that like what is unresolved
the guy's life has a loop it has an
endpoint we know what it is I mean aside
from if you need exactly every detail
about how we eventually get to Beau then
maybe you're left up blood but like I'm
just not that kind of viewer I don't
need to know I'll take it as read so for
me that's not that's not a dangling plot
thread I'm gonna say I don't think the
feeling with male doctor works because
the doctor has a naturally male vibe
I guess Jody is doing your best but I
don't think the doctors female this
comes from a family um I know I'm not
gonna agree because she is working for
me at this point it took it look it took
a while but as I've said Capaldi took me
a while also and he's my favorite at
this point so I'm not I'm not finalizing
my opinion or wit her until her eras
over when she's done when she boughs out
I'll feel more comfortable even
assessing that statement thoughts of
Maisie Williams characters throughout
season 9
like during the second when she appeared
in the woman who lived the rest of them
she was just kind of there I shipped 13
in river that would be kind of cool to
see I'm not gonna lie
check the discord oh yeah I do need to
get over there I just give me a second
did you know the Fight Club is turning
20 yeah I did
[Music]
sorry uh whoa I am behind holy cow okay
I do have to hop over to the discord for
a minute I will be right back
because as a reminder the discord which
is a patreon perk there is a there is a
channel for asking questions that will
get answered on the live stream I won't
end up missing them uh I don't know if
I'll make it enough data to do this
could get messy actually not much there
to work with this time Oh
unicorn Sox versus mittens which is
cuter whichever you pick you're wrong
and I'll happily explain why depends on
the age of the person wearing them on an
adult socks or Huron kid mittens of cure
also depends on the design of the
unicorn that's me over qualifying my
statements Missy claimed that she
brought Clara and the doctor together so
Clara would be an influence on the
doctor and make him look for an
afterlife and find 3w after losing Danny
again like I need to I need to see it I
need to see it again and get full
context on it because a big thing with
Missy like you remember the whole thing
the doctor lies Missy lies Oh like even
for the mass
I thought your review of Joker was
spot-on best one I've seen yet well
thank you Gabe much appreciated made way
too much mac and cheese anyone want some
Oh Donna you're speaking my language Mac
homemade mac and cheese that's my
favorite food ever see here ever play
Dungeons and Dragons or any similar
tabletop yeah I've been part of a gaming
group um kind of fell apart when the guy
who hosted it had a had a kid now he
just had a second one so I don't know
when I'm ever gonna get to do it again
but I enjoy it we do live in a society
debate me Oh
although the piercing in sight of your
observation leaves me stunned and unable
to respond my god we do live in a
society I'll just pack it all in now
it's done isn't it Dumbledore is meant
to love Grindelwald a gay relationship
is fine with me except Grendel Holt is
made out to be an absolute despot
romantic icing that really be encouraged
I don't think at least as presented so
far the narrative isn't romanticizing
him
Dumbledore having romantic feelings
toward him is not the same as the story
actually romanticizing him as a
character or his views so I'm gonna make
a distinction there and I don't believe
that it does what you're implying that
it does it's still not a good movie
regardless what are we debating yeah
whatever comes up thanks for your curse
of Fenric review you finally pinned down
what was bugging me about it even though
I found me in the ending really
effective Oh have you look helped been
uh I always have mixed feelings when
people are like oh you explained to the
thing that always bugged me about this
movie like I I feel slightly validated
but also that I'm like oh god am I just
spreading my cynicism like a disease
Star Wars is diet dune debate me only on
Tatooine
is it Diet doom Tatooine is Diet Doon
though I will give you that rest of Star
Wars know that yeah yeah
thoughts on Trisha Paytas saying she is
transgendered I don't know who that is I
know it's some sort of YouTube drama but
like I you wanna think about something
I'm happy to stick my sand in my head in
the sand over YouTube drama I don't care
and one day I hope to live in a world
where nobody cares nobody cares sadly we
don't live in that world yet but you
know maybe one day I was looking at
endgame reviews and one said this is its
grace there is a gay person it goes
against the Bible
oh I I just I will never understand the
idea of acknowledging that something
exists makes the art that acknowledged
that bad like I just I I don't get that
I never will
apparently we might get a teaser trailer
for series 12 on the 13th of October
well if it does I'm gonna have to cram
it into my schedule but we'll see it
takes you away so Douglas Adams and I
love it the mind is everything for me in
sci-fi and horror psychological horror
and heady sci-fi are fantastic I agree
as it is National Coming Out Day I hope
to come out to my family my worry isn't
that they won't expect me because I know
they will I just don't want a big fuss I
mean like people can't overcome the same
in the other direction like they turn it
into a huge celebration and it's like no
no no I'm just I just wanted you to know
that was also but I mean best of luck
and in any case
have you seen Tim and T for some Batman
yet no I'm like I like four or five
animating DC things behind at this point
I'm behind on a lot
I'm really trying to catch up I
sometimes enjoy the mind-screw sci-fi
but it felt really really underdeveloped
direction listen plotless not in a fun
way in an irritating way again like I
just don't agree I love it what past
villain would you like to see 13 face I
mean you know I'll say Omega cuz I
always say Omega just leave it at that I
know you haven't seen it but the way
class ended was interesting and had big
implications second season would have
been interesting please watch class I
create more time give me more hours in a
day or get me to the point where this is
my living and I don't have to work 40
hours a week in an office when one of
those things happen I will have the time
to look at class
I think this cuz we didn't really learn
anything about face of BOE in the end
not really but I mean like what what
would you need to learn I guess that's
what I don't get what is there to learn
you found out what the face of BOE is
you know through Jax line it's implied
that it that's just eventually what's
gonna happen what what else is there to
know
I guess that's what I've never
understood I don't know what else there
is to actually know class tis ass o bold
have you will you watch Batwoman rudely
rose and kate kane are queens episode 1
was good we'll have to see how it goes I
mean I'm gonna try to watch it but I'm
not catching it as it airs like I said
I'm buried in too much stuff uh hang on
I'm getting I'm getting there I'm
getting there and getting there maybe
oh my god I'm why I'm behind I'm as
behind on the chat as I am with
literally everything ah my favorite 80s
song is Purple Reign by prince and the
revolution is the most emotionally
impactful song I've heard from the
decade please tell me you've listened to
it I've heard it it I mean it's not my
jam but I've heard it yeah I don't
dislike it let me be clear on that
Prince never did a lot for me again I
don't think he's bad I just didn't
connect with him the way most people I
know did have you do how do you play
Dungeons and Dragons what do I need to
start how many people I don't think any
one of my friends will want to play
honestly Andrew you need to find a
gaming group you need to find an
existing gaming group that would let you
join because if you've never done it
before and you're trying to start the
entire thing out from scratch it's gonna
bomb it's gonna bomb
spike from Buffy as the doctors
companion well you could just bring back
uh Captain John hard and you basically
it'd be like having spike I loved
fantastic beasts because finally we get
a Hufflepuff lead character and I love
that he's not your typical leading man
Newt himself has grown on me as a
character and I I'm do I'm more than due
to re-watch fantastic beasts the first
one to see if I like it any better I'm
sorry though crimes a Grindelwald is a
mess it is a mess of a film debate me
being a human being should be punishable
by death because all humans are inferior
by default exterminate exterminate I
mean how can how can even argue with
that see why don't you create a ranking
for every actor to play the doctor that
way you can include the others to play
the but play the first doctor maybe even
Peter Cushing or the curse of fatal
death doctors I mean I'm I have dumb
rankings I've done two rankings of the
doctors they didn't include 13 and it
was only the Canon doctors so it didn't
include curse of fatal death or Peter
Cushing or the scrim of the Schalke
doctor either like what do you mean why
why don't I create a ranking I have this
I've done it twice go back to the
channel have you ever considered doing
PayPal Commission reviews um I've
actually taken one I haven't gotten to
it yet so like I had oh I had someone
who reached out to me that because the
way patreon work didn't want to do it
through there but still wanted to
Commission me for a review and I let
them do that at the same rate as it
would have been through the patreon so I
have done that I would prefer to do it
to the bait John just because it's
easier for me to keep track of it if
everything's coming through the same
source but I've done it
did you see bat woman not yet
what about heterophobia people yes and
what about sasquatches and centaurs and
unicorns I I don't even know what to do
with that statement I don't know if it
was serious or not
I love TMNT versus Batman the clips I've
seen make it look very fun ah this dang
chat it like it gets to where I want and
then it jumps down to the bottom oh yeah
the best reasonable / non omnipotent
superpower ability is duplication fight
me depends on what your um ranking is
best like best as in most effective best
assistant as in most difficult to
counter in combat I mean like what's the
metric would it be what I choose no
shape-shifting always every day twice on
Sunday but like you can't just say that
a superpower is best if you don't say
what metric we're running we're running
that through define your terms my friend
sure let me drop $100,000 just so you
can watch class I think you'll need some
kind of ultimate patreon tier 4 for that
though like well first of all I don't
need a hundred grand to be able to quit
my job but you know somebody wanted to
support me at that level I wouldn't stop
you I would wonder if you're trying to
launder drug money though
okay he's anyone else gonna watch I'll
come in on the Breaking Bad sequel I
might are you forgetting it's coming out
more sheer art comes out next month I
know that's happening excited for that
thoughts on the Supreme Court session
I'll have thoughts wants they hand down
a decision until then I'm actually going
out of my way to not think about it
because I don't want to uh stress myself
out and that's what I'll end up doing if
I think about it you know while it's
going on because at this point nothing I
think about isn't gonna change what's
going on and you know I just gotta wait
to hear what the decisions are if if
anyone doesn't know there are a number
of lgbtq+ rights for Lady cases that are
in the Supreme Court right now in the
session currently going which means
there will theoretically be a ruling on
them which has the potential to be
either a huge leap forward or a massive
step back for lgbtq+ protections under
the law and let me be super clear this
is not special rights this is not
special treatment this is the rights
that this is guaranteeing the rights
that literally all the rest do y'all
have so I gotta wait
the face of BOE died Captain Jack is
immortal it's a glaring plot hole it's
not a plot oh my god okay look look
first of all anyone who doesn't know all
right spoiler Jack Harkness does face a
bow we all know that right right okay
look we don't know how many cycles
through the entire history of the
frickin universe it takes before he ends
up as the face of BOE now as far as what
the doctor said he said that jack is a
fixed point in time he is always there
by the time he dies as the face of BOE
is he
even Jack anymore so there was your nice
little loophole to get out of it just if
you're gonna be a dant Ichabod it if you
gotta make it this they said it Wardle
of anytime the doctor said he was
immortal because that was the best that
the doctor understood it at the time he
said it he didn't know exactly what was
going on if he knew exactly what was
gonna happen he could have known that
the face of BOE is what Jack was gonna
be tongue become way before Jack said
anything he didn't know he said in world
cuz it was the word he had that
expressed the idea the doctor didn't
truly know what was going on with Jack
the doctors not omnipotent he doesn't
know everything he expresses the best
way he could yes he died which means oh
my god the doctors wrong heaven for
friggin bed how do you feel about Disney
Sony's sticking spider-man 3 in the
middle of the 2021 lineup it feels a
little soon I can't remember what it's
what it's going alongside now so I'm not
sure what would you do if a meth Tweaker
tried to mug you I am absolutely no clue
like I'm not even gonna like pretend or
be fun with it I have a zero idea what I
would do watching any Redmayne on the
Breeden on the big screen in 2016 was
what led me to realizing my bisexuality
Newt Scamander is amazing Wow
that's a cute little self-discovery
story nice and there goes the chat
getting away from me again huh favorite
Shiraz ship ah I don't have one because
I just I want Scorpia to be happy I want
that so bad but I also know that Katra
is awful for her one catch was awful for
everybody but I want to score me to be
happy so bad like I want her to find
someone other than contra that's what I
want a ship that doesn't exist yet
all right am I getting mildly caught up
act kinda sorta almost um why do you
think they never do anything with the
idea of mrs. father's body being
possessed by the master during
Davidson's era really bugs the hell out
of me because it wasn't an idea they
actually had any intention to do
anything with all it was was an excuse
to get the mess to get the master out of
the burn makeup that's literally all
that it was it wasn't done because they
had some big plan for new ideas like we
want to put the master in any non crisp
body and that's how they did it and then
they moved on I just want to say I
consider you a hero and your videos have
helped me get through some tough times I
don't get excessively bullied but I have
next to no friends thank you for that oh
jeez
thank you for that Oh God huh I'm glad
it helps like I I don't talk about this
a ton because it seems massively
egotistical but I do have I get
correspondence like that every now and
then through email in chats and comments
people saying that my videos are in my
voice or even the live streams have
helped them through tough times and I am
always deeply deeply moved by that I I
feel like a [ __ ] because I never know
how to respond other than to say thank
you and I'm touched which is true but
feels wholly inadequate you people warm
my heart you really do
dark water is the best Cyberman reveal
agree or disagree um of modern air yes
definitely agree classic era I would
actually say that earth shock is
probably and that was largely because
they hadn't been seen for a ages come on
you dang thing managed to splint my
glasses
nicely done you [ __ ] me myself not
calling anyone else a [ __ ] I try not to
call of other people's stupid I reserve
that for myself and for fictional
characters ah there we go
who's the better duo Abbott and Costello
and/or Laurel and Hardy I'm gonna say
everything castel but that's cuz I'm
partial to really rapid-fire wordplay
whereas Laurel and Hardy were a bit more
slapstick which is still good but like I
don't love it as much
you should pop up and want a passion of
the Nerds of videos I'd be happy to I
love his work and like work we're in
touch like loosely we're aware of each
other but you know I think part of the
thing is we both have pretty well laid
out plans and schedules for what we're
working on and don't cross over a ton
and like there aren't like a ton of
button so glad what would I bring him on
talk about Buffy Firefly angel he just
buried me cuz he he's more well studied
on it than I am
me going on any of his stuff would
interrupt the flow of what he does you
know I'd love to do something with a guy
hey seriously I don't know what it would
be though
is it okay to be Hogwarts house
ambivalent yes yeah liz is a bit
sometimes like you you press her hard
she'll say ravenclaw but you know she
has she has some degree of connection
with well basically every house except
Gryffindor and she's always the ones
that say what they need a WTF house I
guess
hufflepuff sorta is the place where
whoever doesn't fit in the other three
goes but who does have really its own
distinct personality that I don't think
always gets it to do but she's always
quick to say there needs to be a WTF
house where everyone else goes or as as
John Barrowman would say gay fiend or
for all the misfits who don't belong
anywhere else all are welcome and that
from the man's own lips duplication is
practically the best sorry should have
made that clear
you can get so much done schoolwork go
outside do stuff out in the world get
more sleep mmm-hmm all in all in a day
well yeah so John if you're if you're
using duplication basically the way
multiple man does it where you can
duplicate but then take the duplicate
back and have all the experiences that
they had then yeah if it's gonna work
that way that is a very super practical
power sometimes it's better not to ask
questions just let who do who I would
actually agree on that yes
yes I will well said Charleston I have
no idea who board Jack are bojack haha
no I've seen the new birds-of-prey
trailer yeah well I mean I'd saw one
last week if a new one came out I
haven't seen that it just yeah
let's see okay am I actually kinda
caught up ah dang it
I'm really not Wow
alright I'm not gonna get to all the
questions I am sorry folks
huh I am not catching up the color of
your jumper rinse pattern makes look
inspired by Black Panther oh it's always
weird hearing it called the jumper
because that seems to be the the British
term for just a sweater
whereas here jumper is a different kind
of piece of clothing
Skorpio plus anyone else yeah Darwin
yeah pretty much
having Watchkeeper of truck in live at
the time as a kid just right cool uh
what would you want the Sandman to
function like are we talking about the
TV show I want it to not be about the
character I wanted to be about stories
which is ultimately what the comic was
about that's the story about stories and
I love that 20:21 MCU is xiangjian
legends of the ten rings Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness spider-man 3 and
then Thor love and thunder that's not
kind of Disney Plus shows well yeah you
need to treat that it shows us their own
thing I think the vibe on each of those
three is gotta be different or each of
those four rather it's gonna be
different enough from each other I'm not
too worried about that um come on Gib
dang thing given how dark mind control
has been depicted another media Harry
Potter Jessica Jones do you think the
master should reimburse it in their next
incarnation um
if they're gonna bring back the dot the
master and having the mind control thing
as like their deal they need to really
delve into it more because that was
honestly one of the traits that I was
thought was a little bit cheesy about
classic our master and they they need to
really dig into it like kind of like the
way Jessica Jones did like really dig
into how that messes with people because
otherwise it's just kind of a cheap
gimmick that said if they wanted to do
something like that I'd be on board
never discount what you do may not
always seem like it on the surface but
it's important in a ways you may not
know Thank You Maureen are you looking
forward to birds of prey the movie I
I would like it to be good I don't think
it's gonna be whatever you think about
yourself before you have to say to us is
never inadequate right Thanks who's on
first
yeah can a person disagree with the
identification of someone else in their
sexual gender without invalidating their
humanity that's a good question because
we we can't mandate belief or at least
we shouldn't mandate belief but at the
same time I've said before and I stand
by that if someone's a stance is that
gay or lesbian or non-binary a gender
transgender whatever is simply not real
that's you can't really say live and let
live with that position because their
position is just no huh
there isn't a middle ground to be had
there that being said I think the one
area where there is room for for lack of
a better term compromise is that it's
the point at which belief leads to
action so what I mean by that is so I
live in Vermont and one of the reasons I
live here is there is a very Vermont
mentality which is what you do is none
of my business and what I think about
what you do isn't any of your business
and that might sounds cold and
standoffish but it's just that it
doesn't enter into daily interactions
around here like I mean I've had lawn
mowers lent to me by neighbors that I
don't even know their name
and they know I'm not really friends
with them they don't know me I don't
know them but they like oh you need a
hand here and I do think there's a
reason that Vermont was the first state
in the country to have civil unions not
legal gay marriage that was in
Massachusetts but that was later like
civil unions any kind of legal
recognization of same-sex couples I
think there's a reason that happened in
Vermont because it's a very look what
you are doesn't affect me I don't get it
maybe I don't even like it but it's got
nothing to do with me and if we can't if
acceptance is impossible because as much
as I wish it wasn't the case sometimes
it is sometimes for whatever reason
acceptance is not on the table if it can
be a matter of I don't believe that what
you are is okay
or valid but if you're not saying that
directly to a person's face if you're
not shouting at them in the street then
you can disagree with what they are
telling you they are without actively
working to take away their humanity that
you can do I'm personally not gonna say
that that will make me comfortable with
someone if someone thinks I'm invalid or
that I'm sick or I need Jesus what that
one really takes me off you don't know
why your relationship with God piss off
but you know someone who who believes
those things you know I can't change
that but I'd like to think common
courtesy what have them not getting in
my face to tell me that you know
see how many more we're gonna take on
would you say you're more male leaning
or female leaning dude I'm all over the
place
like for real I don't even really gauge
it much anymore I'd land wherever I land
for the day and sometimes it's more fun
sometimes it's more masculine I'm not
tracking it I don't have a I don't have
a you know a dot matrix and a flow chart
cuz right now I'm comfortable with me
however I I happen to be I'm good that's
kind of enough
which doctor companion would you swap
into city of death not considering plot
tweaks or characterization oh I think
city of death where 11 took Amy and Rory
to Paris as a romantic honeymoon thing
would be interesting how would you feel
about a joker sequel or at least Phoenix
playing the Joker again possibly
opposite Batman I actually don't think
that Joker that he did is gonna work
offset a Batman I think he actually
works much better in isolation
considering it's autumn there is an
insane amount of pumpkin flavor food and
beverages have we gone too far in our
creations with all these orange gourds I
mean maybe a little it'll balance though
I'll tell you what we have gone too far
with was something that I actually liked
but I'm now kind of sick of and that's
salted caramel I love salty caramel but
they started putting it in everything
and I'm just kind of done I am NOT a
geek okay welcome anyways flying muffin
ah there it is
which classic and new doctor pairing do
you wanna do you want to see the most
one and 12 I've been done forget about
deceased actors in age um 2 and 10 I
think traveling really annoy Tennant
what do you think it would take to get
Eccleston to return as 9 I'd love to see
it but as you said he doesn't owe us
anything I don't know what it would take
only he could answer I would like to see
him come back I I do agree with that I
just questioned why it was against the
law in the beginning are we talking
about the what the gay marriage thing
it's not that it was against the law
it's that it wasn't codified in the law
because that whenever you're talking
about lawyer you can be talking about
one of two things there is there is
criminalization and there's legalization
and there's decriminalization so certain
parts of the country actually had laws
against sodomy some of those laws were
even still in the books until a few
years ago and why because religiously
driven moral imperatives that's why but
it wasn't so much that I mean until
until gay people started going hey we
would like to get married you know no
one would had actually put on the books
of all banning it it's just nothing
allowed it either so it was one of those
nebulous things that had to be worked
out in the courts and it was how do you
feel about storylines that deal with
Nazis and Nazi inspired groups because
I'm really really uncomfortable with
something like Hydra and crisis on earth
acts I have much more mixed feelings
than I used to about that sort of thing
especially since you know without
pointing fingers as to who qualifies
like
Nazis are kind back
and like even setting aside you know Oh
people just call you a Nazi not like
there are literal Nazis
there are literally Nazis that are like
having marches and rallies huh and in
the in the wake of that the the
trivialization of them through
entertainment does get to me in a way
that didn't use to not so much that I'm
like I I don't want any part of it but
it's not as clean-cut as it used to be
and I'm not entirely sure how I feel
about that I feel like I feel like the
way I feel about that is evolving and
isn't done doing so favorite doctors
theme from new who um I prefer the
twelfth doctor's a good man is the name
of the track oh I think it might be
something close to caught up I watch The
Dark Knight Rises recently I quite liked
it but I don't see why Gotham season 5
had to do the same stick I know right
Gotham was many things it was not
derivative up until that fifth season I
do not know what was going on with that
that city of Death swap would be amazing
oh thank you
not bad from the top of my head and yet
there are not pumpkin Oreos seriously
how hey I'm not even sure what's the
thing about that
why doesn't Eccleston want to come back
to doctor ooh um a litany of reasons he
left on bad terms because of clashes
with both the BBC as an entity and also
some of the people who were working
behind the scenes at the time and also
it has come out recently that he was
anorexic at the time which lends it a
whole other level of going back to that
space and Riaan happening that character
that he played when he was sick with
something that he's tried to get a grip
on since then you know is that's asking
a lot of somebody but I mean he hasn't
really said flat out I won't come back
because of X we just sort of know
influence of a lot of the stuff that's
gone on over the years he seems to be
using up he started doing conventions
like for my money maybe he'll he'll do a
big finish first and that'll be a
stepping stone but I mean who knows two
and 10 would be intriguing possibly very
funny to an 11 would be amazing I think
to an 11 are too similar I actually
don't think there'd be a ton of mileage
on that come on come on come on come on
I am gonna wrap up soon I've gone over
time um oh I have almost caught up here
without diving into religions did you
hear that VeggieTales is getting
rebooted again rebooted again I didn't
know it had ever been rebooted in the
first place not something I've ever
watched I'm aware of it
I've heard of it I know what it is but
that's it
you dabble in cosplay alright have you
ever dealt with prosthetics like demon
horns and the like I don't do
prosthetics I'm not that good with
makeup um I've been a testing ground for
someone else to work out prosthetics
with my daughter's mother because she
does she does theater and she has had to
learn some elaborate makeups to do that
I was her tested don't like to work on a
bullet-hole
injury in the forehead so I've had like
stuff done to me but I can't do any of
it myself
so I I don't I don't dabble in
prosthetics but the closest I've gone a
god I've got I've got vampire fangs that
are you know that are molded to my teeth
but that's about as close as I get I
hope that if the illness was is a big
factor I'm returning that he could
approach the role with a refreshed mind
and state I mean that would be lovely
but again I I don't want to I don't want
to tumble too far down the the rabbit
hole of oh you know what would it be
like if Eccleston came back whatever
because I mean I've said I've said it
before there's only so much I've sort of
the dream casting you know oh maybe this
thing like I just my brain just kind of
stops me like it's probably not
happened and then like I can it's hard
for me to force myself to even let my
brain go down that path if you could
delete any Doctor Who episode from the
Canon which would it be hell-bent
probably yeah yeah I mean I know for me
that's like the boring obvious answer
but it's true haha oh that's good
silence of lambs a Clockwork Orange in
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest are
better Joker films than Joker uh you can
you can drop two taxi driver on that as
well it's practically the same movie
gotta go good night remember you and
everyone else or the council I just
attend the meetings thanks Ben I am
gonna wrap up do you have any thoughts
on the use of the common autistic traits
and the characterization of the doctor
and other similar characters I don't
because I don't know enough about the
autism spectrum
and I haven't done enough research into
the use of those characterizations and
traits to have a say like I I
acknowledge that they are there to a
certain degree and one could even say
that the doctor has at times been neuro
a typically coded but I do not I do not
know enough about any of that about
neuro atypical behavior in the first
place and about the representation of
such I like I got no business saying
anything
thoughts on Heaven Sent heavens that's
amazing goodnight love you and your work
keep it up thanks a lot
it's your favorite film of 2019 so far
my favorite film of 2019 so far is the
lego movie to think on that one for a
bit so I have a good background and an
iPhone I want to start a YouTube channel
doing scripted fifteen to twenty minute
things dive into specific aspects of a
piece of media but I don't have a topic
to talk about
I mean I'm not gonna tell you what to do
and I'm because you have to pick
something that is that is of interest of
you because if you pick something like
oh I should do that you turn it into
work and then it's not fun and then just
you don't keep up with that so I mean
just get a piece of paper start writing
down ideas start writing down things
that you like that you have thoughts on
movies TV shows video games whatever
things like oh this and this and just
look at the the options and just see
what thoughts come to you see if any of
them are something you can build on
add fake lasers to the mix hahahaha well
said Channel pub the Syrah and Buzz
Lightyear need to hang out in there
green and purple outfits round heads and
delusions all right
excited for Star Wars no nervous so I am
where your glasses upside down with the
rest of stream sure but only insofar as
I'm wrapping it up right now
so no I'm not actually gonna keep doing
that cuz I I see myself I'm like that
just looks too damn stupid but I hope
that hope that everyone has a good night
hope that you've had a good week so far
that you have a good rest of the week
and just remember you're beautiful
you're valid you are loved you are the
council I just run the meetings and til
next time
this council is adjourned good night
everybody